♪ ♪
>> Greg: WHAT TO DO WHEN YOUR
TAX BASE FOR EASIER CITY.
IF YOU ARE LEFT WING WORKS, YOU
PROMISE TO TAX WHOEVER STAYS
MORE.
>> YOU REALLY WANT TO CHANGE
THINGS IN THIS CITY, THEN
EVERYONE BETTER TO CHANGE A LOT
OF THE WAY WE LIVE MORE
FOUNDATIONAL HE.
IF YOU JUST TALK ABOUT IT AND
FEEL SELF-SATISFIED, GOD BLESS
YOU.
THAT’S NOT ACTUALLY GOING TO
CHANGE THINGS.
WHAT CHANGES THINGS IS
REDISTRIBUTION OF WEALTH.
TAX THE RICH AT A HIGHER LEVEL
PEER THIS HAS A LOT OF COCKTAIL
PARTY COMFORT GOING ON RATHER
THAN PEOPLE HONESTLY DEALING
WITH THIS ISSUE.
HELP ME TAX THE PEOPLE, HELP ME
BUILD AFFORDABLE HOUSING IN
WHITE COMMUNITIES IF YOU WANT
DESEGREGATION.
>> Greg: THIS IS WHAT HAPPENS
WHEN YOU ELECT A COMMIE WHO
CAN’T DO MATH.
NOT ONLY DID THEY SPREAD AT THE
BELIEFS, THEY CAN’T EVEN PAY FOR
THEM.
IT’S BEEN A DOWNWARD SPIRAL OF
LEFTISM, DRAGGING EVERYONE DOWN
WITH IT, AND HERE’S HOW IT’S
DONE.
ONE, TAKE OVER A CITY THAT WAS
KICKING BUTT THANKS TO
REPUBLICANS.
TWO, CREATE POLICIES THAT
REVERSE SUCCESS AND ENACT
DISASTER.
THREE, FUNNEL THE MONEY TO PET
PROJECTS INSTEAD OF IMPROVING
QUALITY OF LIFE.
FOUR, VERY IMPORTANT, VILIFY
POLICE, WHICH DRIVES EARLY
RETIREMENTS WAY UP AND
RECRUITMENT WAY DOWN.
FIVE, DRIVE OUT INVESTMENT DUE
TO UNCERTAINTY AND FEAR.
SIX, TAX WHOEVER IS DUMB ENOUGH
TO STAY, ME.
A BONUS POINT, DO THIS DURING A
PANDEMIC.
I GOT TO ASK, WHY ARE WE STILL
HERE?
I DON’T UNDERSTAND IT.
IF CITY LEADERS CAN’T PROTECT US
STORES ARE LOOTED AND BURNED AND
THEY DENY REALITY AFTERWARDS, I
DID A ONE MINUTE SEARCH,
THOUSANDS OF ARTICLES WITH
STATISTICS SHOWING SHARP
INCREASES IN VIOLENT CRIME, BUT
IN NYC ALONE, MURDERS UP 34%,
SHOOTINGS 87%, BURGLARIES, 43%,
AND PEOPLE ARE HOME.
I COULD CITE TO SPECIFICS,
CHILDREN SHOT DEAD, MAD MEN
ATTACKING PEOPLE BRICKS AND
SPEARS, AND ATTEMPTING DAYTIME
RAPE IN A SAFE SUBWAY SPOT.
I COULD GO ON BUT WHO IS
LISTENING?
AT THE DEMS OR THEIR MOUTHPIECES
WHO MOCK THIS MISERY.
>> DEMOCRATIC CITIES ARE IN
CHAOS RIGHT NOW, IS THIS WHAT
YOU WANT FROM JOE BIDEN, AND
THEY’RE GOING TO TAKE YOUR
COUNTRY AWAY AND THEY ARE TAKING
DOWN THE STATUES --
>> CRIME IS RISING IF THEY DO
YOU FUND THE POLICE --
>> OH, MY GOSH, IT’S SO BAD,
DEFUND THE POLICE.
IT’S LIKE --
>> Dan: NOW, SIX WEEKS LATER,
HOW THEIR TUNE HAS CHANGED.
>> I THINK DEMOCRATS IGNORING
THIS PROBLEM ARE HOPING THAT
IT’S GOING TO GO AWAY.
JOE BIDEN MAY BE AFRAID TO DO
IT.
I’M NOT SURE, MAYBE HE WANTS,
MAYBE HE IS.
HE’S GOT TO ADDRESS IT.
WHAT’S HAPPENING NOW IS
HAPPENING UNDER DONALD TRUMP’S
WATCH.
THE WRITING HAS TO STOP.
AS YOU KNOW AND I KNOW, IT
SHOWING UP IN THE POLLS.
IT’S SHOWING UP IN FOCUS GROUPS.
IT IS THE ONLY THING RIGHT NOW
THAT IS STICKING.
>> Greg: WOW, THAT IS AMNESIA.
MY, HOW THINGS CHANGE WHEN IT
IMPACTS THEM POLITICALLY.
WHICH IS WHY THE ONLY WAY TO
MAKE THEM CARES TO CALL THEM
OUT, THAN FOR THE POLITICIANS
OUT, OR LEAVE FOR SAINTER PARTS.
TENNESSEE, WYOMING, IDAHO, JUST
DON’T BRING YOUR LEFT WING B.S.
WITH YOU PEER PART OF AMERICA
STILL NEEDS TO FUNCTION.
EMILY, IT’S AS IF
MAYOR de BLASIO WAS INVENTING
NEW WAYS TO BE THE WORST MARE
EVER.
IT’S LIKE HE THINKS, NO, IF I’M
GOING TO GO OUT WITH A BLAST,
I’M GOING TO MAKE MYSELF REALLY
LOOK AWFUL.
>> Emily: RIGHT, LIKE HE’S
RUNNING OUT OF IDEAS.
I WILL SAY THAT THE FISCAL RUT
IN NEW YORK CITY RUNS DEEP.
WE KNOW THAT THAT CITY SEE’S
RESIDENCE’S INCOME AS ITS OWN
INCOME AND THE CITY ITSELF HAS
AN INCOME TAX IN ADDITION TO THE
STATE FROM WHICH THEY COLLECT
OVER $11 BILLION, AND EVERY
DOLLAR OF THAT GOES TOWARD
COVERING THE ABOUT 80,000 CITY
EMPLOYEES’ PAYROLL.
EVERY DOLLAR OF THAT.
DON’T FORGET ABOUT THE OPEN THE
BOOKS EXPOSE WHERE WE ALL
LEARNED THAT THE CITY SPENDS
OVER $2 BILLION A YEAR ON
OVERTIME.
SO, THAT CITY IS A ROTTING
CESSPOOL AND WE DON’T NEED THAT
RIDICULOUS MARE TO CONTINUE TO
SHOW US.
I WILL SAY ONE WORD REALLY
QUICKLY ON THE MOVING ELEMENT
BECAUSE I ALREADY MOVED FROM
CALIFORNIA AND A BREAKS MY HEART
TO SEE THAT STATE CONTINUE TO
CRUMBLE.
IF YOU’RE GIVING THE CHOICE TO
ACTUALLY EXERCISE SOVEREIGNTY
AND A CHOICE FOR YOUR TAX
DOLLARS AND HOW THEY ARE SPENT
OR THE HEALTH OF YOUR COMMUNITY,
INVESTING IN LAW ENFORCEMENT AND
SAFETY AND FREE SPEECH AND
PROPERTY AND ALL OF THOSE THINGS
WE HOLD DEAR, DAMN RIGHT YOU’RE
GOING TO EXERCISE IT AND
ABSOLUTELY I WOULD MOVE.
>> Greg: RIGHT.
DAN, YOU ARE FROM NEW YORK.
IS IT EVER GOING TO COME BACK?
ARE YOU AN OPTIMIST OR A
PESSIMIST?
>> Dan: NO, I’M A PESSIMIST,
SORRY.
I DON’T HAVE ANY FAITH IN
HUMANITY LEFT AT ALL.
I LOVE YOU GUYS, THOUGH.
AND LADIES, YOU’RE GREAT.
HERE’S A REASON, LIBERALS ARE
JUST IMMUNE TO FACTS.
IT’S LIKE AT AN EARLY AGE THEY
GET A VACCINE AND FACTS JUST
CAN’T PENETRATE OR SOMETHING.
IT’S NOT LIKE WE HAVEN’T TRIED
ECONOMIC REDISTRIBUTION,
MILLIONAIRES’ TAX BEFORE.
I TOOK A FEW NOTES.
FRANCE TRIED IT, REMEMBER THAT
CUSTOMER AT 75,000 PEOPLE FLED
THE YEAR APPEAR MY HOME STATE OF
MARYLAND WHERE I USED TO
LIVE, TRIED THAT TOO APPEARED TH
MILLIONAIRE
TAX COST PEOPLE FOR THE STATE, 3
PEOPLE LEFT.
WE’VE TRIED THIS STUFF BUT
WHAT’S PARTICULARLY INFURIATING
ABOUT THIS, I DON’T OWE YOU
SQUAT.
LIBERALS OUT THERE, LET ME BE
CRYSTAL CLEAR AND IT WAS A PARTY
CANDIDATE WOULD GET UP AND SAY I
DON’T KNOW YOU WILL DAMN THING.
I DON’T OWE YOU SQUAT.
I DON’T OWE YOU MONEY, YOU’RE
NOT ENTITLED TO MY MONEY.
IF YOU ARE IN ABLE-BODIED HUMAN
BEING WITH TWO LEGS, FUNCTIONING
ORGANS ANTIBODY, IT OFF YOUR
CABOOSE, REMOVE YOUR RUMP FROM
THE CHAIR AND GO TO WORK!
GET A JOB!
I DON’T OWE YOU ANYTHING!
NOBODY OWES YOU ANYTHING COME OF
THE WORLD DOESN’T OWE YOU
ANYTHING, AND I JUST WISH THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY WOULD STAND UP
AGAINST THIS STUPID
REDISTRIBUTION ARGUMENT AND SAY
WE ARE NOT HELPING HERE.
PEOPLE NEED TO WORK, THAT’S WHAT
MAKES THEM BETTER OFF.
>> Greg: I WILL SAY THIS, I’M
GLAD THAT BOOK "OVERCOMING
SHYNESS" BOOK I LET YOU REALLY
WORKS.
>> Dan: YES, IT WORKS REALLY
WELL.
THAT WAS A BIG PROBLEM.
>> Greg: HEY, CAN’T
PROGRESSIVES AND SOCIALISTS
ADMIT THAT FOR THEM TO INDULGE
THEIR DREAM, THEY NEED
CAPITALISTS.
IF YOU KEEP DRIVING CAPITALISTS
OUT YOU’RE GOING TO RUN OUT OF
THE MONEY.
THERE IS A DOG BARKING.
>> Dana: SORRY.
FIRST TIME IN THE WHOLE
PANDEMIC.
>> Emily: IT’S OKAY.
IT’S OKAY.
I’M GOING TO SHARE TIME WITH
JASPER, I’M A JASPER FAN.
>> Juan: GREG, I THINK
DIFFERENTLY ABOUT THIS THEN YOU
BECAUSE I THINK POPULISTS ON THE
LEFT AND THE RIGHT THINK THAT
THESE BIG COMPANIES LIKE
WALL STREET REALLY TOOK
ADVANTAGE OF THE LITTLE GUY,
ESPECIALLY AFTER 2009, AND TOO
BIG TO FAIL AND THESE COMPANIES’
EXECUTIVES GETTING THESE
EXORBITANT GOLDEN PARACHUTES AND
THE LIKE, THAT’S NOT FAIR TO THE
AVERAGE WORKING AMERICAN WHO SAW
THEIR SALARIES IS STAGNATING.
THAT’S ONE ARGUMENT.
BUT LET ME SAY, MUCH MORE
BROADLY, ABOUT NEW YORK CITY.
I’M FROM NEW YORK, I LOVE
NEW YORK, AND I THINK ANYBODY
WHO SAYS, OH, NEW YORK IS GOING
DOWN THE TUBES, I’LL TAKE THAT
BET.
I’LL TAKE THAT BET NOW.
PEOPLE TOOK THAT PATENT D
’70s, OH, THOSE ECONOMIC
PROBLEMS IN NEWARK.
REMEMBER FORD SAID NEW YORK CITY
DROPPED DEAD?
THEN AFTER 9/11 PEOPLE SAID,
NEW YORK IS NEVER COMING BACK.
IT’S LIKE BETTING AGAINST THE
STOCK MARKET.
THE STOCK MARKET MAY HAVE A DIP
BUT LONG TERM THE STOCK MARKET
GOES UP AND NEW YORK IS GOING TO
GO UP AGAIN.
>> Dan: BECAUSE IT’S NOT RUN
BY LIBERALS.
>> Dana: TALKING AGAIN --
>> Greg: GIULIANI.
I WAS GOING TO SAY.
I WAS JUST GOING TO SAY, JUAN IS
COMPLEMENTING GIULIANI.
>> Juan: NOW, I’M A NEW YORK
GUY.
>> Dana: IF HE WERE TO RETURN,
IT MIGHT BE SOMETHING IF THOSE
TWO WANTED TO RETURN BUT I THINK
YOU HAVE TO LOOK TO THE NEXT
GENERATION THAT WOULD COME IN
AND TRY TO FIGURE OUT A WAY TO
DO IT RIGHT.
I DO WANT TO TELL YOU THIS,
THOUGH, I DON’T KNOW IF NEW YORK
WILL TRY THIS BUT LOOK AT WHAT
CALIFORNIA IS A FLOATING PIER
THEY HAVE SO MANY PEOPLE LEAVING
THAT WHAT THEY HAVE DECIDED TO
DO IS TO GO BACK AND TAX
PREVIOUS EARNINGS.
PREVIOUS EARNINGS ON YOUR
ACCUMULATED WEALTH FROM BEFORE
YOU LEFT.
SO, THIS TRULY IS HOTEL
CALIFORNIA.
YOU CAN CHECK IN BUT NOW
APPARENTLY, YOU CAN’T LEAVE EVEN
IF YOU HAVE A U-HAUL.
>> Greg: PS.